she was amazing
she cared so deeply for what she did and
she cared so deeply about
the residents that she looked after and
ultimately she paid the price for them
patricia crowhurst worked as a carer for
over
20 years it was a job she loved
but her family is worried she put
herself at risk
i think there needs to be some form of
investigation as to why so many people
have
died and why that it's being allowed
why so many health care workers and
nhs staff and nurses
everybody some covid deaths could be
investigated
by the health and safety executive which
enforces
workplace safety sky news has learned
the hsc has received 91
fatal disease reports relating to health
and social care workers 26 of these are
in local authority care settings
for the hsc these are huge numbers put
in context
last year it investigated a total of 147
workplace deaths experts say the hsc
must decide whether employers
failed to protect their staff was that
risk reasonably
foreseeable did we select the correct
ppe
did we have enough staff were they
properly supervised there
are there are many many things to
consider what if the workplace says
we just couldn't get our hands on the
right ppe the health and safety of staff
is the responsibility of the employer
health safety and welfare and then
they've got to do everything that's
reasonably practicable to safeguard
their staff
the hsc has the power to fine or
prosecute
nhs trusts or care providers in breach
of the rules
i've spoken to one bereaved family
who've been
contacted by the hsc they didn't want to
talk on camera
but tell me they welcome the hsc's
involvement
because they've got serious misgivings
about the level of protection
offered by their relatives employer
they're not alone many families are now
starting
private legal proceedings provision of
ppe
is one of the big issues one of the big
questions that we're being asked about
were they provided with proper ppe
was it fit for purpose and if not why
was that the case
and if we're able to establish that the
ppe simply wasn't there and
should have been that may be the first
hurdle the families need to get over
the department of health and social care
says it's taken steps to remind
employers of their responsibilities
in a statement a spokesperson said the
safety of our nhs and social care staff
is
paramount and employers should follow
their legal duty
to report the deaths of any staff who
die as a result of exposure to
coronavirus
we've been working around the clock to
ensure ppe
is delivered as quickly as possible to
those on the front line
patricia crowhurst is one of the 250
health and social care workers
sky news understands have died with
covid
the hsc says it's committed to getting
an accurate picture
of those deaths and expects more will be
reported
in the coming weeks laura banduck sky
news